i want to give merle a wonderful
christmas surprise i'm a little stressed
i won't lie
we have a few hours to get this place
ready
did you like it yes i liked it are you
kidding me i've been sobbing
uncontrollably
happy holidays everyone i'm arya and if
you don't know me
the one thing you should know is that i
do love the holidays
i do love giving gifts and this year i
want to give something really special to
my girlfriend merle who i've been dating
now for a little over a year
honestly merlin's had a little bit of a
rough time as of late obviously we're
all going through the stresses of the
pandemic but in her case in particular
she's had a bit of a
not so fun time particularly with her
apartment long story short merle went
back home to spend some time with her
mom and the person that she left in
charge of her apartment turned out to be
a complete animal who led a roach
infestation fester
among other terrible things including
potentially animal abuse but
whatever terrible stuff terrible guy
terrible situation for merle
and hopefully i can make things a little
bit better by giving her a wonderful
christmas surprise
okay so surprises what are we gonna do
for merle i think one of the first
things that comes to mind for me is i
want to give merle
a perfect apartment christmas makeover
because obviously
with the roach infestation the apartment
it hasn't been the most fun place to
live so i think brightening it up with
some holiday decorations
that would be perfect and very holiday
miracle i want to infuse the place with
a holiday spirit
so maybe i can maybe hire a santa claus
off of craigslist
although i don't know if it's really
coveted safe for her to sit on santa's
knee
nor do i really want her to be sitting
on the knee of some strange old man
oh maybe maybe we hire some carolers for
stuff for like a social distance
caroling session
ah see okay it's coming it's coming we
should have a meal that night
maybe get one of merle's favorite dishes
annoyingly i think one of merle's
favorite dishes is from a place in new
york
maybe i can write them maybe they can
ship a dish over ah
is it safe to ship food across the
country it is right
we'll find out all these surprises aside
i think honestly something that would be
very
heartwarming and special is if merle got
like
holiday messages from people like for
like from viewers so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to go into my instagram
settings and hide merle from being able
to see my stories
and then post an instagram story asking
for people to send in video messages
for merle for the holidays and hopefully
it'll be
pretty heartwarming hey everyone so i'm
planning a huge holiday surprise for
merle and i'd love to have your help
with it if possible
she can't see this story i hit her from
it but basically if you could send in
holiday video messages for merle i'll
compile them together edit it
and show it to her and hopefully
hopefully she'll love it basically all
these surprises need to take place over
the course of one day
however parts of them do involve needing
merle out of her apartment which
a little tricky considering you know
we're in a time where we're expected
to stay indoors so i think what i'm
going to do is i'm going to call one of
merle's best friends rachel
gayeski who is another producer at
buzzfeed as well and maybe
you know she can get more out of the
house or
something vegan rachel gayeski she's
single gentlemen
oh rachel hi i need your help
uh pulling off a christmas a miracle a
christmas surprise for merle
yes it involves you needing to get her
out of her apartment next monday if
possible
i need her out of her apartment so if
you could uh
i don't know just plan something what do
you have
what do you guys normally do out of the
apartment in these times
and i'll just be like hey do you want to
work for my apartment today
and we can put a little love island on
in the background
oh that'll that's what i'll get her the
love island's what's going to lure her
ah we love it it's a real treat of a
show chris and chem
okay great so yeah invite her over do a
little work session a little and then
just just at the end of the day we'll
just get her back to hers and
the the christmas miracle will little
bit we'll be ready for her
oh this is so romantic oh it's a real
treat
rachel do you want to say anything to
any gentleman suitors out there that may
be watching
oh gentlemen i'm looking for a suitor
a christmas miracle for rachel gayeski
ladies and gentlemen
the irons are in the fire right now i
think let's get the ball rolling
[Music]
and you know what since this probably is
the best time of year to try and make
wishes and dreams come true
i'm going to reach out to one of merle's
favorite actresses if not her favorite
actress
sherilyn fenn who played audrey in her
favorite show twin peaks
to see if maybe she'll record merle a
holiday message as well
it's a crazy long shot i don't even know
how to reach out to her so i'm gonna try
twitter
and we'll see how that goes
[Music]
okay so the day of the big surprise is
now here i'm
a little stressed merle is out of her
apartment i believe rachel texted me
rachel picked her up and they're
doing their work from home day social
distance thing together
and so i think that's going to give me
at least a few hours to do the
transformation of the main part of her
apartment
uh and then hopefully the other
surprises kind of just like fall into
place
after that however i'm very excited
about all the surprises and the fact
that my good buddy jack
is coming to help document this whole
thing i see a criminal over there i see
the ah look at this festive
festive criminal thanks so much for
coming
for this man thanks for having me dude
what are we up to here man
what are we doing okay merle's our
apartment right now so basically we need
to transform the entire place into like
a festive
winter wonderland before she gets back
in just a few hours
so it's a little stressful but i wanted
to look good i wanted to look as over
the top and as
christmasy as possible luckily we do
actually have a guy coming a guy called
dr christmas i don't think that's his
legal name
uh he's coming back with a crew to do
like uh
a safe christmas transformation it's
like i said they do it for a living
so hopefully him and his crew can make
that transformation happen
in the short amount of time first things
first let's just go into merle's place
uh check it out you know and make sure
everything's looking good and you know
that she's
somehow not secretly still here or
something i don't know man
rachel says she's with her so uh
there we go
she's not here the kitty's here though
hi genevieve
oh she's resting this oh so this is the
space
right now it's 11 30. so merle probably
will be working with rachel
at least hopefully till the end of the
workday maybe sooner
uh dr pranga is coming shortly doctor
dr christmas you can do it in the
afternoon right
[Music]
do you want me walking into the scene is
that what you want no you can be in the
car i'll come up to you it's kind of how
we greeted each other earlier
hello dr bob how are you we're excited
for this this magical transformation
you've got planned
i i hear you've worked many a porn set
before
well i haven't worked a porn set i've
decorated once
hi everybody i'm bob pranga i'm dr
christmas basically i bring christmas to
your front door
wow it's fantastic you could hide a body
back here
how do you know we don't today we're
going to be helping my buddy arya out
and romancing a little bit more of his
girlfriend merle apparently she doesn't
know that christmas all of a sudden is
going to be dumped in her living room
the things that guys won't do to keep
their ladies i'm telling you
[Music]
because it is a modest sized apartment
we're going to try to give you
as much bang as we can in here we're
going to go in there and doll up the
place
probably a little bit over the top
because i think he really wants her to
be overwhelmed so i brought all kinds of
things
ranging from nostalgic christmas to
over-the-top glitter and
hopefully she will like it except for
this transformation yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah is this your
world dr christmas
is this my world is this your world oh
no i very seldom never show up
i'm getting a little antsy that mom i
just show up out of the blue so
you know let's uh i'm gonna give her a
quick call
hi handsome hi my love i just got a
i just got a quick moment on the the
shoot with jack right now i just want to
give a quick call to
to see if you are uh you're still not
home right
no no i'm at rachel's right now i'm just
hanging out doing all the work
do you know what time you're planning on
on being home
uh well we just started a new episode of
island
watching in the background so i don't
know maybe finish this and then rachel
can just drop me off afterwards so
probably like
40 minutes or something oh yeah uh
well
you know uh um why don't
you okay what is going on yeah i don't
know i just
i just jacqueline did some weird driving
turn and
you know he said oh god he scared me for
a moment there
drive safer jack that way rachel doesn't
drop you back off if you're fine with it
we can pick you up and get some food on
the way
uh back home tonight i mean you're not
really saw me on jack's driving skills
all right love you bye
that was all over the place
i didn't think i was gonna say it till i
until i called so it's 4 30 right now
the sun's going down so i think it's
about
a good time to go pick up merle uh
because i think i think we're pretty
much set to go yeah
yeah yeah alrighty i i think i see
a beautiful tall woman there
how to work it with rachel go fine it
was fine i mean
we had little violin on the background
so it was great that's fun jack and i
had a nice day huh jack
he almost ran over an asian man what
if it's okay jack jack just needs to
come in to use the restroom if that's
okay
i don't know i'm asking for jack but
what are you gonna do tonight with
kaylee jack she's in newport
yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is so cute a polar bear
yeah okay all right this is like truly
out of control above and beyond
i just wanted to transform the space
because i know you haven't been back
here for a while so i figured you know a
little christmas cheer
to make up for the weeks of stress and
anxiety okay but real talk is this for
me or is this for you because i know
that you love
christmas it's 50 50. yeah there it is
oh i love it this is really really sweet
i mean
it's also hard like being away from home
this was a very thoughtful
and time intensive and let's be honest
insanely over-the-top surprise but
really really thoughtful
i have not felt like comfortable in my
apartment in a really long time
so as wild as this is it actually i just
think it's so sweet
there's more surprises though what the
hell is this now
what can you possibly have is it alcohol
so i can't even imagine what else you
can possibly give me at this point
what do you think is in that i really
don't know
i'm scared the garlic
there's garlic why is this sheen
oh you know how did you know cause i saw
the chili oil
yeah they mailed a full kit for you are
you kidding me
okay this is easily the best part of
this entire surprise i
this is so incredible are there noodles
in here the edges are in there
this makes me so happy
i haven't had these in so long you can
have it
in two that is gonna years me cry which
is so
stupid and she does love these news i
love [ __ ] it's my
it's legitimately my favorite food in
the entire world wow this is a great ad
for them but they didn't pay us for this
i can't even tell you how happy i am
right now no i you could have
all of this insanity without any of this
i would have cried because this alone is
just such an amazing surprise
for the fact that you made this like
insane christmas experience moment i
appreciate it and i love you thank you
i don't know how you keep doing it
you're the best gift giver of anybody i
[Music]
know
[Music]
it's so delicious on some i'm gonna eat
the whole portion all by myself
we got one other surprise it's always
been a rough year for most people
uh but it's been a pretty hectic time
for you specifically and so i just
wanted to
take a recap all this sort of stuff off
with a little collection of small
christmas gifts
from other people no i can't look at
this this is going to make me cry i'm
already crying i don't even know what it
is
hi marlo and ben calling and
reaching out to you because oh my gosh
you've been going through
so much i can't believe it with the
roach infestation this is insane
literally having construction done at my
house right now there was a leak and the
floors buckled so it's crazy to be doing
this
i have you i just oh my god i can't
handle this aria
you are a big twin peaks fan so i always
oh my god
part of our sacred family oh my god
oh and all that good stuff sticking
around watching us for all these years
i cannot handle it just
[Music]
this is insane there's more holidays
happy holidays hi merle i'm gwen
and i just want to wish you a happy
holiday season oh
my god i just want to say that i love
you mel thank you for everything that
you create and share from
food to sustainability to sexual health
i imagine it can't be easy putting
everything out there online and being so
vulnerable so i just wanted to make sure
you knew that you were really
appreciated
and that you've made a big impact on my
life and i'm sure the lives of many
others as well
so thank you so much i think you put out
such beautiful thoughts and emotions
into the world and
i'm just so grateful to know that you're
there and that i can watch your videos
and
feel connected to the things that you
talk about you just always make me smile
you're not afraid to speak about the hot
topics which a lot of people are scared
to do
and you're fearless me and my merlia
kiki oh
merry christmas oh my god she made it
she made the cookie
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
yes i liked it are you kidding me i've
been sobbing uncontrollably there are
tears all over my laptop
my laptop actually oh are you happy
oh yeah i'm insanely happy i can't
believe it was so nice
that was so sweet i'm still crying that
was so sweet
thank you so much everybody was so nice
i don't ever get to see like the faces
of the people that follow me
so it's so nice i'm like i'm so happy i
can't even i don't even know what to say
thank you so much i'm glad this was so
nice
there's still one more surprise no there
can't be another surprise
one last surprise
troll the ancients you'll take
[Music]
i mean this was like above and beyond
any expectations i could have had for
christmas
this year has been [ __ ] for everybody so
i think it's just like a little extra
love a little little surprise goes a
really long way
also i cannot believe you got sherlin
fenn that makes me want to like i don't
even know pull
my hair up also seeing all the messages
from people that follow me was like
unbelievable i feel like i never
actually get to see these people so
that meant a lot to me
[Music]
regardless of where you are whether or
not you celebrate christmas hanukkah
kwanzaa whatever you celebrate hopefully
we can all end this year with a bit of
love
positivity and uh being kind to each
other
yes that that's better yes thanks and
being kind of nice to each other thank
you all as always and happy holidays
i didn't know you that was good that was
better than what i was gonna i didn't
know what to do
it was good so
[Music]